encuentra el máximo factor común de los
siguientes mono mios ok y con mono mios
se refieren a expresiones que tienen un
solo término que hay que son un bonche
de cosas multiplicándose y estas tres
expresiones claramente son cada una de
ellas un solo término entonces son mono
mios y lo que queremos es encontrar su
máximo factor común o que hay una
expresión que divida a cada una de estas
expresiones y que además sea en cierto
sentido la expresión más grande que lo
hace ok y para hacer eso a mí lo que me
gusta es tomar cada uno de estos
términos y partirlo en la multiplicación
de los factores más chicos que los
componen ok en el caso de estos números
eso es su factorización en primos
entonces podemos empezar por ahí vamos a
dividir a esta expresión en sus partes
más elementales estuve aquí es igual el
10 es tal cual
2 x 5 esta es su factorización en
números primos no podríamos encontrar
números más sencillos que multiplicados
nos den 10 después esto lo vamos a
multiplicar por aquí a esta se no la
podemos escribir en términos más simples
entonces la vamos a dejar tal cual como
una c
y eso está multiplicándose por d al
cuadrado y este de al cuadrado si lo
podemos escribir como multiplicación de
cosas más sencillas las cuales son pues
de x b bueno vamos con el siguiente la
factorización en primos de 5 es
simplemente un 5 porque 5 ya es un primo
por el c no lo podemos dividir mes
entonces lo dejamos tal cual al d
tampoco lo podemos simplificar más
entonces lo dejamos como un d y el
último término escribimos la
factorización en primos de 25 y eso es 5
por 5 5 por 5 25 y cada uno de estos es
primo muy bien luego sea el cubo es la
multiplicación de
de por sí por cierto y de cuadrado es
simplemente de x b entonces ya partimos
cada uno de estos términos de estos mono
mios en su descomposición en partes más
fundamentales que pudimos encontrar que
en el caso de las variables es
simplemente la variable y en el caso de
los números de su factorización en
primos y ahora lo que queremos hacer es
encontrar el máximo factor común y para
eso lo que vamos a hacer es buscar en
estas descomposición es en factores
primos podríamos llamarlos así cuáles
son los factores que tienen todos los
términos aquí por ejemplo todos estos
términos tienen a un 5 entonces déjame
lo círculo este término tiene un 5 por
aquí
este término tiene un 5 por acá y este
término también tiene un 5 escojamos
este entonces en esta factoría ción en
factores primos todos tienen un 5 así es
que el 5 forma parte de nuestro máximo
factor común y además podemos ver que
todos los términos también tienen una c
así es que vamos a circular las
se dice y ponerla en nuestra
factorización del máximo factor común y
podemos observar que cada término tiene
también una vez
d
hice
y el asunto aquí es que estos tres
términos no tienen ningún otro factor
común porque aunque el primer término y
al tercer término les quede todavía otra
d en su factor y zación al segundo
término ya no le queda nada así es que
el máximo factor común no tiene dos
veces tiene nada más uno y lo mismo pasa
con ésta se cuadrada
así es que nuestro máximo factor común
es
5 por c por d ok y no podía ser más
grande que eso porque uno de nuestros
términos del cual estamos encontrando el
máximo factor común es 5 cede y ningún
factor común puede ser más grande que
una de las expresiones de las cuales
estamos sacando el máximo factor común